some of the finest moments in hollywood
history were captured at the bonanza
creek ranch it will now be forever
associated with one of the movie
industries most tragic
we've had two people accidentally shot
on a movie set by a prop gun we need
help immediately so was it loaded with a
real bullet or one i don't i cannot tell
you that we now know a lot more about
the incident that led to the death of
cinematographer helena hutchins killed
by a single shot fired by the actor alec
baldwin he and the crew member who'd
handed him the gun unaware it was loaded
with live rounds
the armorer on set hannah gutierrez read
in a podcast after her last movie had
talked about the intensity of the job it
was also my first time being head
armored as well
and how was that you know i was really
nervous about it at first and i almost
didn't take the job because i wasn't
sure if i was ready but doing it like it
went really smoothly i think loading
blanks was like
the scariest thing to me police say
their investigation continues no one has
been arrested or charged the tributes
continue for helena hutchins her husband
matt posting a photo of her with their
son she inspired us all with her passion
and vision he wrote her legacy is too
meaningful to encapsulate in words
those who worked with her wonder whether
her death will lead to prop guns being
banned on set today i'm saying yes i
mean there's there's an aesthetic
argument one can make about it um
whether or not it looks you know as good
but
today i think i i definitely feel like
i'm questioning those kinds of things
this is this has made me think very
differently but if you think you can
succeed where they fail already the
makers of this police drama have
responded by banning what they call live
guns from their set
from now on they'll use pellet guns and
special effects those who've spent their
career on set say that should be just
the start i hope that this will be an
agent for change because there's really
no reason there never should be someone
who dies making a film i think that
it'll definitely be looked at and there
are ways that you can mitigate the the
risk
by doing it in post-production
by changing the shooting angle it's been
reported that before thursday's incident
several crew members had walked off the
set of rust over safety concerns
including misfires of a prop gun
the movie's producers say they weren't
made aware of any official complaints
concerning weapon or prop safety but
they would review procedures safety they
said was their top priority
there are still so many questions over
an incident that to many was unthinkable
one that's left an industry shaken and a
family grieving a loss they describe as
enormous greg milam sky news los angeles